see a lot of couples here a lot of
attractive ladies who aren't legal it
doesn't look like uh
I'm not looking in that direction see
that was adult creepy what I just did
uh I'm seeing a lady right now sorry
it's not going well though it's not
going well uh my girlfriend asked me
that question the other night how hot am
I on a scale from one to ten
terrifying question
I don't know why women are still asking
us that but I was like you know what I'm
gonna get it right I'm gonna crack the
code now I want to be realistic yet
generous
so I said well you're a whopping 8.5
she was pissed
she yelled at me and I was like well you
know I'm a little upset about it myself
you're not the only one who wanted you
to be a 10.